- [Instructor] If you want
to follow the footsteps
of Taylor Swift,
you would need to have
written your first novel
by age 11, have signed an
artist development deal
with a record company by age 14
and be releasing your
first album by age 16.
So, this clause, even
before we think about
or the sentence even before
we think about the grammar,
it puts a little bit of
undue pressure on you
if you wanted to be like Taylor Swift.
She's a little bit of a overachiever,
but anyway, let's focus
on the grammar here.
So, if you wanted to follow
the footsteps of Taylor Swift,
you would need to
and then they list three things
that you would need to do.
You would need to have written
your first novel by age 11,
have signed an artist development
deal with a record company
by age 14 and be releasing
your first album by age 16.
So, when you read that,
have you noticed anything?
Each of these clauses,
have written starts with
a certain form of verb,
have written, in other words,
you could say a verb clause,
for have written, then you have signed
which feels parallel to have written,
it feels like the same form
but then you say and be releasing.
Be releasing is a different
form than have written
or have signed, so this
last clause is breaking
the parallel structure here,
so I definitely don't want no change.
If I wanted it to be parallel,
I would say and have released,
and, let me write that down
before I even look at the choices.
Have, let me write it over here,
and have released
because it was and have released
your first album by age 16,
you have have written, have
signed and have released,
that would be parallel,
so I would knock those out,
so let's see if any any of
these choices have that.
Be signing,
no I don't wanna all of a
sudden make this parallel
to this and then it breaks
it with have written,
so I wanna rule that out.
Have signed an artist development deal
with a record company by age 14
and have released your
first album by age 16.
Yeah, this is, now it's all,
we have nice parallel structure.
The same, we have have released,
we have have signed and have written.
Be signing an artist development deal.
Be signing once again,
this would break the parallel structure
with have written, so we wanna
rule that one out as well.
So, feeling really good about this choice.